so the last couple years if you read The
Wall Street Journal you watch the news
you're going to hear about inflation
interest rates Everybody's scared about
these two numbers inflation is so high
Jerome Paul has to keep increasing
interest rates what is the next big
thing they're going to talk about in
2023 you ready it's unemployment here's
what we're going to do in this video
today there's multiple formulas they
have to come up with unemployment I'll
share those formulas with you there are
six key factors that is causing this
economy to be an anomaly that even
economists cannot predict what's really
going to happen to the economy you'll
see what those six things are and
another thing we'll talk about is called
Phillips curve it's something you need
to know about that has to do with
unemployment
[Music]
foreign
so let's get right into it a couple
things you'll hear people say today's
unemployment rate is 3.5 but that's for
you three but our U6 unemployment rate
is 7.4 and people will say what the hell
is u3 and you'll six we'll talk about
that today but let's just look at the u3
right the unemployment rate historically
U.S governments started tracking
unemployment rate in the 50s but Based
on data they can kind of track what
happened in the 20s and the 30s the data
they get is the worst unemployment rate
we've ever had in the history of America
was in the 30s and the lowest we ever
had was 1.2 percent during World War II
in 1944 but it's 1.2 percent because
everybody was kind of forced to go to
war so you didn't have a choice you got
a job go to war and if we want to talk
about post-world war what happened to
the lowest unemployment rate it's 2.9
percent in 1953 and we're at 3.5 today
it's not a big difference which means
kind of it's not going to get any better
than it is today maybe a small little
point one point two percent but not
dramatically which means the only
Direction it can go right now is what go
up now here's the thing to keep in mind
since then we've had 11 different
recessions and the U.S government has
tried to control markers to not allow
unemployment to go too high and we'll
talk about that but a couple things we
need to know six key factors throws
everything that we've used out the
window on why today's economy is an
anomaly number one we've never had a 128
month economic expansion and that was
caused because money was so cheap zero
to one percent interest rates we've
never done that in the history of the
economy before I want to give a quick
shout out to our sponsors Aura it's very
important thing for you to do if you
don't already have a product like this
while home robbery and losses in America
is declining year over year
digital losses every year is
skyrocketing 2021 was 7 billion alone
000 is lost every hour Aura protects
what you value the most in one easy to
use app such as Identity Theft
Protection parental control secure VPN
antivirus password manager spamless
removal it does a ton and more so
protect you and yourself from America's
fastest growing crime try Aura free for
two weeks and see if any of your or your
family's personal information has been
compromised click on a link below to get
started with your 14-day free trial with
aura number two covet when's the last
experience of pandemic the way we did it
threw everything off number three
trillions of dollars pumped into the
economy nearly 50 percent off everything
we have in the economy currency-wise was
fed into it in two and a half years
we've never experienced that before
number four in 2022 the FED increased
the interest rates seven times that's
seven times in one year you know when's
the last time when Chris seventh times
when do you think 2008 by the way the
record is eight times no five and a fun
fact here do you know what year we
lowered the rates the most times 2001
you know how many times we lower the
rates in 2001 you ready not five times
not eight times not ten times eleven
times we lowered the rates in 2001.
again it's a very unpredictable climate
today number five great resignation
increase wages people were normally
getting a job for 40 Grand new you have
to pay them 65. we're getting a job for
a hundred thousand dollars you have to
pay 150 000 it was a strange time when
he came down to making job offers the
last year and a half two years Point
number six is population actually move
like physically they moved a lot of
people moved out of California first
time since 1851 California's population
went down 330 000 people left New York
to other places Chicago Illinois moving
to Texas or Florida so whether it was
politics or it was working remote why am
I living in New York and paying so much
cost I can work remote at a national
Nashville and get paid the salary in New
York I'm just gonna move so again we've
not experienced that before so again
these six key factors happening at the
same time during a two and a half three
year period is what's causing an anomaly
where nobody can predict the future but
there's four different types of
unemployment let's talk about it number
one frictional unemployment this has
nothing to do with the economy this is
people are moving from one job to
another job transitioning out from one
state to another state so there's a 30
60 90 day window of them not having a
job that's called frictional
unemployment the second type of
unemployment is structural unemployment
so for example let's just say we're
having a much I.T here you know
Engineers here cost is going up you're
like listen I'm not going to do this
moving forward we're going to hire a
thousand employees out of India you know
500 Engineers from Armenia I'm gonna go
offshore I'm not going to do it here
that's structural where those jobs are
lost here right or you know newspaper
industry is a big industry boom online
comes in why do we need newspapers we
don't boom 25 unemployment in a year
they're going into different Industries
there's a little bit of a structural
unemployment chat gbt restaurants now
don't have fast food they have
automation this is the kind of stuff
that causes unemployment to go up but
it's purely structural number three is
the title will explain it itself it's
called seasonal unemployment which means
Christmas Is Here Black Friday is here
let's hire a bunch of different people
to work retail but then January 15 we
don't need you anymore summertime New
York hotels super busy we need to are a
bunch we need to work at the hotel boom
season's gone everyone's going back to
school it's not here anymore Farmers oh
this is our season Hiram boom two months
from now we don't need a minute more
seasonal unemployment just happens every
year and last but not least it's the
cyclical unemployment this is a part of
capitalism boom and bust recession kind
of like what we're going through right
now when people are making money they
spend money they go entertain they do
all this stuff when the market goes
through its bust they're not spending
money the economy kind of contracts a
little bit that's the cyclical
unemployment so those were the four
different things that cause unemployment
but here's a kicker every month the
Bureau of Labor Statistics puts out
stats and in the government level and a
lot of Corporations companies there's
the one statistics everybody looks
forward to seeing some are concerned
some are enthusiastic about it it's the
unemployment rate when it come comes out
like oh my God rates are good we're good
why many reasons if people are having a
job they're paying the bills crime is
lower re-election for politicians if
it's high you're not getting reelected
crime is up a lot of uncertainty people
are not spending money they're not
investing into different communities
it's a very very important indicator but
the question becomes well Pat how do
they figure out the formula for
unemployment let me share with you their
formula on how to come up with the
unemployment rate here's what it is okay
so the U.S employment report is based on
two surveys that they do the first one
is the establishment report which asks a
random sample of employers how many
people are on the payroll the second one
is the current population survey also
called the CPS in which approximately
sixty thousand households whether their
family members are working or looking
for work okay so don't ask me why it's
60 000 and why they do the way they do
it but that's how they get the numbers
now here's a formula they take the
number of unemployed divided by the
total labor force times a hundred okay
I'm sure you're having so much fun right
and getting all these statistics but as
if it's not already complicated there's
six different ways they measure
unemployment you ready let's have some
fun together it's U1 U2 all the way down
to U6 here's what it is you won these
are people that are unemployed 15 weeks
or longer you too they have completed
temporary work or recently lost their
jobs u3 which is the one we typically
hear about is the official unemployment
rate total unemployed as a percentage of
the civilian labor force u4 ready the
total unemployed plus the total of
discouraged workers those who have given
up looking for work because they don't
think there are jobs available you five
the total of unemployed u3s plus
discouraged workers u-force plus all
those marginally attached to the labor
force those unemployed who would like to
work but have not looked for work
recently and last but not least U6 the
total unemployed u3s plus discouraged
workers u4 plus marginally attached
workers u5 plus part-time or
underemployed workers who want to work
full-time but can because of economic
reasons so now that you know what the U1
U2 u3 U6 is you'll see why u3 is three
and a half percent unemployment about U6
is 7.4 right but but here's the point
why do these things matter historically
there's this thing called Phillips curve
Philips curve means when inflation is
high unemployment is low they're inverse
like directly complete opposite okay
when inflation is low unemployment
sometimes can be high so today what has
Jerome Powell been doing they increased
interest rates
seven times okay back to back to back to
cause inflation to go down
if they cause inflation to go down
unemployment should go up okay so let me
give you a little bit of context here in
history in the 70s both interest rates
were high inflation was high and
unemployment was high that's what you
call stagflation Jimmy Carter era in the
90s both inflation was down and both
unemployment was down that's the last
time we were in a budget surplus during
Clinton era when you hear about that
that's because the economy was great in
the 90s we were managing our finances
properly as a nation today it's a little
weird again those six key factors we
talked about but if everything goes the
way it is the next data you're going to
hear about them talking about
unemployment going to five percent six
percent possibly seven eight percent is
going to be happening by Q3 Q4 maybe q1
of 2024. again if history repeats itself
that's the direction we're gone so what
does this mean to you may say well okay
I got data now what do I think about
well if you're an employee yourself and
you're sitting here saying what if I get
laid off the market always loves great
employees with great attitudes that go
above and beyond that are experts that
are constantly getting better because
it's very very hard to find people like
that if that's you you're going to be
all right number two if you're an
employer or an entrepreneur business
owner this is going to be a very good
season to recruit Talent period because
as the layoffs take place somebody
getting laid off doesn't mean that is
bad Talent it could simply mean that the
company at the time didn't have the
money to keep them all this means is you
can pick up some great people right now
the next three six 12 months in case
unemployment does go up having said that
I want you to watch this video I Shot I
think 2018 2019 eight ways to prepare
for market crash this is pre-covered
very interesting video if you've never
seen it click here to watch the video
and if you got value from today's video
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
foreign